chimpanzees have a lot on their minds
researchers have been trying to get
inside their heads for decades and along
the way they've discovered new twists in
how chimps think and behave 50 years ago
Jane Goodall chimps tick blades of grass
and twigs into soft termite mounds to
collect and slurp up the nutritious bugs
deep in the forests of the Republic of
the Congo chimps must deal with huge
termite mounds covered in hard crust
these Apes wrap one or both hands around
sturdy twigs to bust through the crust
then they use sutler grips on smaller
twigs to clean termite tunnels to snag a
snack chimps don't roast the termites
before eating them but they may
understand that food can be cooked and
maybe even prefer some foods roasted
when given the option animals at an
African chimp sanctuary usually chose
too much cooked potato slices over our
they were also willing to wait a full
minute for three cooked potato slices
rather than downing a raw slice right
away as evidence of chimps complex
behavior mounts so does controversy over
whether the Apes can reveal anything
about ancient members of the human
evolutionary family four million years
ago ancient hominids may have forged for
termites and savored foods naturally
roasted in wild fires much as chimps do
today that's one theory but some
anthropologists aren't convinced that
debate will probably continue and so
will the search to uncover exactly
what's going on in a chimps head